we begin in eastern Libya where
thousands have died in devastating
floods and more than 10,000 are still
missing on Sunday more rain fell in one
day than over the past 40 years it burst
two dams Upstream channeling a wave of
Destruction towards the port city of
Dona Michael Apple
reports a witness to the disaster points
to where the flooding that would
devastate DNA was Unleashed
two dams holding huge amounts of water
burst sending a wave towards the city
satellite imagery shows them before the
floods the first dam was 12 km Upstream
the second dam was on the city's
outskirts when the dam walls crumbled
almost like a revers tsunami the water
cut through dona's neighborhoods
destroying Bridges roads and homes
sweeping residents out to sea as the
waves struck the low-lying coastal town
DNA had a population of around 100,000
the human cost of the disaster is still
being counted the death doll is huge uh
it it might reach 2000s really uh but we
don't have a definite number right now
uh maybe later today or or maximum by
early morning tomorrow we do we do have
definite numbers that will be ready to
share Libya has two governments the
leader of the Eastern Administration in
t Brook says the immediate focuses on
emergency
response we have directed the government
to form a specialized committee to
assess the damage instantly begin the
Reconstruction of roads to facilitate
Transportation restore the electricity
and to take all immediate and needed
measures in that
regard Aid is already beginning to
arrive at nearby airports as the scale
of the catastrophe becomes clearer Mike
leppel Al jazer
well Aid is beginning to arrive to help
flood victims in Libya turkey has sent
three plane loads around 170 rescue
Personnel from the Turkish disaster
Management Authority were on board they
landed in Benghazi a short while ago
let's go live to resour said our
correspondent in stul so what Aid is
turkey sending
rle well it's quite a wide range of
package of the aid that has been sent
where three military planes Turkish
planes that landed in Benghazi under the
forces loyal to khif Kar so according to
the the the disaster and Emergency
Management Authority of turkey they said
that they have sent 168 surface and
underwater uh search and rescue
Personnel they have sent the rescue
vehicles and boats the raincoats the
Food hygiene Keys generators blankets
and also the tents and so on and they
said that this is the first respond to
the international call Aid call made by
the Libyan government and they said that
in the coming days they're going to even
provide more yeah why is turkey one of
the first countries to send Aid to
Libya well there are several reasons for
that geopolitical reasons economic
reasons and also the business reasons
the the the the the other reasons as
well so one of the first is that turkey
is one of the key Ally of Trio based
government particularly and keeping that
relations good with trioli is quite
essential for turkey particularly when
it comes to its position in the East
Mediterranean which turkey is in a
competition with with with France and
and and and Greece so that's why it's
very much important geopolitically on
the other hand so turkey uh has huge
investments in in in Libya particularly
Turkish construction uh companies the
scale of their investment is is is
tremendous and also turkey is trying to
seize this as an opportunity to develop
an aid diplomacy particularly with
Benghazi based government which is led
by khif and turkey uh particularly since
2018 on have been on bad terms with and
now they're trying to seize this as an
opportunity that they can build the
relations with with B gazi uh as well
and also on the other hand humanitarian
reasons as well just around 7 months ago
turkey had one of the largest the
biggest disaster in its recent memory
Eastern 11 Eastern cities of turkey they
have been hit by two powerful
earthquakes and 50,000 people died and
also then we have seen the wildfires
across the country then the floods as
well so turkey was is is very much used
to these natural disasters they have a a
a a Personnel that is thousands of
personnel that are trained in that sense
and so that's why turkey has been one of
the first country to response the
international Aid call made by the
Libyan government R sadar in Istanbul
thank
you all right an update now on our top
story on Al jaaz this hour in the floods
in Libya we can confirm that the death
toll from those devastating floods in
eastern Libya has risen significantly
let's bring in our correspondent Malik
trainer in Tripoli Malik what are the
latest
figures
well according to Isam Abu zba he's the
minister of interior in the pero
government in eastern Libya he's now
stated that uh the the the death toll in
the city of DNA has risen to over
5,200 now we haven't had uh you know
International organizations or the
Libyan red crescent uh uh confirm those
numbers uh but listen we spoke to the
Libyan red crescent earlier and they
told us uh
more than 2,000 confirmed deaths and
more than 9,000 nearly 10,000 uh people
registered as missing uh so you know
officials here expect uh the death toll
uh to be around 10,000 I mean just shows
the devastation that the city of DNA
faced uh due to the stor to storm Daniel
I mean Folly this is cities like DNA
here in Libya are very close-nit
communities so you'll have you know a a
block in in a neighborhood that just one
family you know uncles cousins brothers
sisters will all live I mean we've heard
of of of of stories of families losing
71 family 70 members so so the situation
is dire it's desperate uh but I think uh
in the coming uh hours or days uh the as
authorities are able to reach the city
uh will be able to understand uh the
devastation more clearly as well as a
death toll in the number of people who
who were who were injured or suffered
due to due to this flood so just to
remind our viewers a significant
development in eastern Libya authorities
in the east of Libya saying that the
death toll now in just the city of Dona
after these devastating floods has risen
to over 5,200 as Malik was telling us
there Aid I understand has been coming
in from a number of countries including
Algeria but how long Malik until it gets
suda and those affected
areas so I spoke uh just about an hour
ago to a volunteer who was part of a
convoy trying to reach uh DNA uh the
communications are are very are very
it's very hard to talk to people and
don't know the communication lines are
are terrible at the moment uh but he
told me he expects uh that they will be
able to reach the city within hours if
that's possible we're just going to have
to wait and see uh but I the hope is
that uh this Aid and and and logistical
support can reach these people as soon
as possible Malik thank you very much
again a considerable rise in the death
toll in eastern Libya where 5,200 people
have now been confirmed dead there by
the authorities in the aftermath of the
devastating floods there Malik trainer
thank you very much for the update let's
now get an update on a storm Daniel from
our weather presenter Cara and the
impact on Libya Cara and what next in
the coming days well the good news is is
that it has weakened dramatically and
Fallen apart as it moved from Libya into
Egypt but it was a very powerful system
with a pretty nasty history that began
last week in the southeast of Europe it
caused flooding in Tura as well as
Bulgaria and Greece torrential rain
about 6 months worth fell in two days
and that turned Villages into lakes now
it's sat in the Mediterranean pulling
into the weekend further south into
Northern are areas of Eastern Libya
there it is edging in bringing
exceptional amounts of rain now we don't
have a lot of data for this area of the
world we do know however that Benghazi
gets about 3 millimet of rain on average
in
September well to the east of that a
city received on Sunday into Monday 140
millim in just 12 hours that caused the
rivers to flood the dams to collapse and
of course that lethal flash flood the
good news is the storm moved very
quickly out east to Egypt taking Heavy
Rain not as heavy as what we saw in
Libya some very powerful winds though we
are expecting some pretty nasty
sandstorms but behind it clearer Skies
which is good news for places that have
been the worst hit and those recovery
efforts are now underway Cara thank you
very much for
that now joining us to speak more about
the situation in Libya is Hani shanib
who's president of the National Council
on us Libya relations and he's
originally from DNA the city hardest hit
by these flights he's joining us from
Phoenix Arizona in the US thank you so
much for being with us uh Mr shanib I
know you've been speaking to friends and
family in DNA and are you getting first
a clear picture of the scale of This
Disaster well thank you for having me uh
Frankly Speaking DNA is truly besieged
by the its own nature of geography uh it
is actually wedged Under the Mountain
the Green Mountain in Libya and with the
tragedy that has happened uh it they
have lost pretty much connection with
the rest of the world to prove this it's
about it took about 24 hours at least to
appreciate the intensity of and of the
damage that has occurred in DNA up until
now they still do not have
communications with the outside Aid that
is supposed to be coming into DNA is
trickling in a dismal manner
uh it is really stuck on the road almost
all the roads are closed totally
destroyed and there is no access to the
city right uh the numbers are still
going up and um and as you recall it was
160 yesterday morning when I announced
that it was 2,000 and more and through
my communications with friends and and
relatives I have uh lost many of our own
family in there uh and we're still
looking for many others but the
estimates are going to be increasing by
the minute as they are Excavating and
pulling out bodies yeah um they are in
Desperate status at this point there is
very very minimal and slow Aid that is
coming in they have not seen the Turkish
supplies coming into there they have not
seen uh any significant donations right
the United States of America in its in
its might has is trying to put a
assemble something but so far the
donation from the United States has only
been
$100,000 right which is absolutely disal
for this status in indeed and a number
of countries including turkey as we've
heard Algeria also sending in aid but
the question is who is leading the
response on the ground because of course
Libya is governed by two rival
administrations one in the East and one
in the west what's the administration in
the East led by warlord Khalifa haftar
doing to help those in need absolutely
this is this is a very good question um
the the divide in Libya has a major
impact on how uh services are provided
including uh disaster relief um there's
a huge resentment and a fracture between
the two sides you know the East and the
West uh there is a resentment even in
the streets as to why has the East been
neglected Ed all this time and there is
procastination in trying to resolve the
financial dispute between the East and
the West uh to the extent that even
individuals and and groups that are
trying to help from the West bringing in
through basic cars private cars and so
on uh are not very well received in the
East uh you would expect that there
would be some more support uh and
understanding but this is not happening
because of the historical fracture that
has exist that is definitely impacting
coordination on the ground to answer
your specific question there is a lack
of human capacity in Libya including in
the systems that are providing the
relief at this point I just read the
report by the red crescent and it is
incomplete and it is very poorly
prepared so if the locals are unable to
deliver proper reports and requirements
it is surprising and it's not surprising
to see that the support from the
International Community is limited Dr
shanib just a quick question you you
talked about the East being neglected a
and the two dams in DNA uh were
constantly said to be flooding the city
even before storm Daniel can you tell us
more about the situation in the East the
infrastructure what it what it's like
there and why people feel they are being
neglected and marginalized compared to
the rest of the
country absolutely as a position that
has been constantly providing missions
to Libya and I've visited DNA quite
frequently I have been shocked that a
city of 100,000 people draining
150,000 does not have a single hospital
that is functioning the only hospital
that is functioning in DNA today is a
rented Villa that has five bedrooms
providing the services to the population
this is not new this is been been going
on for 42 years it has caused the
alienations and the political turmoil
since the days of Gaddafi every minister
of health and prime minister will drop
by Dara will make statements about
supporting the city and then ignoring it
completely this is the cam this is the
straw that has broken the camel's back
the erosion in the dams in DNA are not
new they have been reported repeatedly
in including in scientific journals from
2018 2011 and moving on no official has
paid attention to it okay and the
notifications had been made repeatedly
that this has to be done urgently this
is not just a natural disaster this is a
human disaster as well as a result of
the neglect of the city Dr Han shanib
thank you so very much for joining us
thank you for sharing your views there
with us Dr Han shanib is president of
the national Council on us Libya
relations joining us there from the us
we really appreciate your time thank
you thank you